Laura Jane grace coming in from against
me she's also got a new book out called
[ __ ] confessions of punk rock's most
infamous anarchists sellout yeah I know
welcome do you get [ __ ] for saying
[ __ ] cuz so many like there's so many
activists to get angry if you use the
word and regardless of the intentional I
I mean I hate the word I don't like the
word at all oh you don't why would you
kill your book that I mean a lot of my
book is about self hate and internalized
transphobia that's room so you know I
mean in that way it's a fitting title
I'm Jason by the way I'm not supposed to
be here this is not my show cool but I
might be on my show but something
happened oh yeah yeah I think I had to I
had to have a heart a test on my heart
that's what it was yeah remember okay
I'm alive I'm super fit and [ __ ] but I
had to do it to make sure because I'm
super paranoid I'm sure you can
understand I've got issues just as well
as you right yeah it's not a competition
you know that only if you want you know
I don't become a [ __ ] other likes it
that you feel you were even you know
that's not a single I am yes
alright I'm super into you right so you
know like your style like your head
tattoo
I like your neck tattoo thank you we
should make out let me know right now
cuz it be open but maybe later Yeah
right
off-camera we want to be YouTube
sensations right you right be [ __ ] Jimmy
how did I guess I mean this must be the
question that everybody asks but what
kind of reception did you get from your
fans cuz I mean they'd did against me
was a really established band um with
with what with coming out yeah
transition I said big judges like
Halford came out his gay but that's it
that's a different jump than right on
yeah I mean people are really supportive
and people really like surprised me you
know like totally surprised me I I
actually like I felt like if I wouldn't
have been upfront though and come out
and just like told people that it would
have been different you know that if I
had like started to exhibit like I'd
started like wearing eyeliner or
something like that that people would
have been like oh guy liner or some
something like that you know so I felt
like I kind of had to come out and just
say you know so you didn't you try at
one point and then go like I can't do it
and then restart
uh well I had a suicidal nervous
town about a year and a half after
coming out um and and kind of bottomed
out a little while was that because you
thought it was a mistake like I'm not I
don't I don't know this is the pressure
you know really it was like just the
pressure and I had like an adverse
reaction to the hormones that I was on
so like I quit hormones cold turkey for
a couple months and when you quit
hormones cold turkey that really after
after being on them for like a year it
really affects you taking pills right
yeah pills and then switch to injections
and ejections are a lot more even-keeled
huh could you become a woman which means
you get all emotional like a woman
men are emotional too yeah but they
don't they I cause I've had people on my
podcast at my radio show I had a
transgender girl to guy and when he got
the shots he got a beard he said he had
to go through puberty and he began to
yeah right so he was said that he went
through all these things that well
weight wheel did when we were like 11 or
12 or 15 whatever it comes and so that
means I assume that it's a reverse I
know a little bit about transgender and
I was just added to club on Tuesday
super into them super into girls that I
understand your pain cuz you're born a
man I do don't [ __ ] it look at you
laughing really what you got a book
about companies I just think it's Jason
is really selling himself what is like
in case your understanding my pain he
doesn't know what I was in I won't
understand more of your pain you know to
me the book I don't read I've got two
books and I never entire book I just
want to look at the pitches and I'm not
seeing any of you naked that's bumming
me out
that's I'm just looking through here I'm
like it's a lot of words here looks like
he drank a lot and did some drugs are I
did yes that doesn't help
I say you started doing drugs 14 years
old right um yeah you know a pretty
young age I kind of like was like dead
set on it
you know about do it like it was
something I was like I'm going to get
into drugs I'm going to start smoking
cigarettes these are terrible when I'm
going to do it yeah I'm gonna find drugs
why did you why what made you do that
when you're that um young I wanted the
experience you know I guess that had a
lot to do with it and then experience
like and experimenting with the way that
like drugs affected dysphoria you know
like for me smoking weed really calms me
and real
like took away the panic like doing coke
were like took away the feelings of
dysphoria just like numbed me I didn't
care about anything all the same with
drinking and you know it was South
Florida so like drugs were rampant it
was either easier to find like cocaine
an acid than it was to get someone to
buy you alcohol
you got married twice right yes so I had
two women so is it hard to like sleep
with women and were you not into it or
do you just do it like while there's no
I mean I you know that there's a
difference between gender identity and
sexual identity and I mean like I really
like sex sex is great you know I feel
you are you attracted to women now or
met I am oh okay not dude um you know I
I don't have a shot that's yeah he's
he's not holding on strong it's really
early I bet two sips yeah well drink
some old coffee because here I come good
for you Jason did you I guess I don't
even understand like because when I was
13 were you always just an explorative
person like they just wanted to
experience everything I'm asking when I
was 13 I hadn't tried a hamburger yet
and you're doing [ __ ] cigarettes and
blow and we talking about yeah no I did
Sam's a late bloomer though so late
what's so dangerous about a [ __ ]
hamburger I just didn't like different
things I liked it what I liked I know
what I like okay and that's what I do
that's it yeah I don't need to look
around drugs never hi you you missed dad
it was pretty good he's a little OCD Sam
he's got weird thing with tastes and
textures he's a weird just like this is
where I like you're not a good I know
you're not a good case study for that
cuz you you've done a lot of weird
things I most people haven't done i'm
thing on the opposite side of the
spectrum yeah what we're on be better
nothing weird I don't do weird stuff I
like my thing why such a veg can stick
your finger on something I like I didn't
mean like [ __ ] Ernie I mean like get
you your name get your toe wet whatever
it's what is just for you
what is this for yeah that's a feeling a
disconnect feeling of misalignment you
know um feeling like what's in my head
doesn't match up you know like I you
have your self-image that you can think
about you know like oh this must be the
way I look and every time I see a mirror
I'm like it's like a feeling of
disconnect and how do they know because
there's all these
people that say well it's only a mental
thing how do you know that it's not just
a mental thing that needs to be fixed
instead of saying this is really low
gender is in your head I mean like a
cliche example would be okay if you're a
soldier and you go over to Iraq and you
get your genitals blown off
are you still male you know right so to
me it is like you would identify
yourself as male regardless of if you're
your dick and balls left or not so I get
that it's a psychological identity right
and so when you realize I guess it's not
you know you're not walking around as a
teenager being like I should have been
born a girl or were you what well I mean
like you know I didn't hear the word
transgender no-tell it's probably like
19 or 20 right you know it was like
pre-internet days or it's not like I you
know I could go to the library and there
was no books on it or anything like that
so like for a long time I thought I was
schizophrenic I thought like there was
like twin souls inside me warring or
something like that I just didn't
understand it I didn't know what was
wrong with me you know like I thought
okay I guess I'm gay you know maybe I'm
gay I don't know you know I just I
didn't know yeah I can understand that
yeah you know those weird confusing
thoughts majorly Ferdie like that sorry
to throw you in but please throw myself
throw myself in in 19 [ __ ] 74 so when
you are write songs that help you with
your writing like all this it's a kind
of crazy stuff you're thinking in your
head make sure you have to get it out so
yeah and that's how it so you lose do it
in your songwriting where nobody knew
yeah I mean at first it was like you
know like alluding to it and like hiding
things in metaphor but then like you
know by like our fourth record I like
there was a lyric on our fourth record
that was if I could have chosen I would
have been born a woman and I remember
like singing it in the studio and being
like does anyone think that's weird that
lyric and everyone's like now at school
go with it you know and just no one no
one ever said anything so became like
this like thing of okay like how much
can I say how can far can i push it is
anyone paying attention was your
employer with somebody said wait wait of
it you meant that for real that was just
a lyric afterwards
you know like sure or when you come out
were they like yet we were listening to
your lyrics we we kind of [ __ ]
gathered I had like one or two friends
afterwards who said like oh yeah I kind
of gathered but I was like no you [ __ ]
y'ever do you think that because of it
the way it is these days that it's a
little more acceptable that you have
done this then can and committed to it
or lucky let's say you oh you're the
same age you are 20 years ago would you
have gone through what you're going
through right now and become the woman
that you are mean because the times have
change and you're not going to be
chastised as badly I feel like people
are way more acceptable of transgender
and people being gay or bi or whatever
it is 20 years ago like I'm bi I came
out just recently I don't think 20 years
ago I would have said I figured what it
kept it to myself right I think I just
would have been fired I think I would
have lost my job right well I mean you
know I think for most trans people that
it becomes like not an option to not
come out so you knew you were going
right and and for me it was like you
know consequences be damned if this cost
me like my whole entire fan base or
whatever you know like it wasn't it
doesn't matter dealing is because of
your age as well like you got a little
like when you were young because you
said you knew when you were little do
you think the older you got you knew
that it was like this is the healthiest
thing for me to do well yes but also
like I think that I probably would have
come out at a lot younger of an age if I
wouldn't have done what I did with my
life as far as I Kuenn I was 20 years
old I started touring playing like 200
plus shows a year for like 10 years you
know signed to a major label like so
there was like all these things that
distract me along the way and like you
know I came out at the end of a major
label like contract and was just like
you know just didn't know who I was
anymore you know and I it was like
coming to the realization of like okay
if this is the way I felt when I was
five this is the way I felt when I was
10 15 20 like I'm always going to feel
this way you know like I I need to
accept this and move the [ __ ] on you
know did you ever like dress up on your
run away I read the like I think Kalyan
said that like years ago I think you
just like given who's still Bruce would
dress up and go out did your dress up
and like I'll [ __ ] I'm gonna get caught
yeah I mean like I well I lived in
hotels like I lived in a hotel for like
two years and and I mean like there was
great anonymity in that you know and but
I had like systems where I was like okay
I got my hotel keycard
if this like demagnetize is for some
reason what do I do okay I'll hide a
pair of spare clothes in my car outside
so I could change so I don't have to go
to the front desk to get a new key or
like get a hotel
where I can crack a window to crawl back
in through the window if I need you know
it's kind of rock and roll to be in a
dress dresses look I feel like if you're
the singer of a band and I see you
dresses alone I'm just like [ __ ] yeah I
would honestly wouldn't think you know
he's trying to become transgender but
like he's rocking out right right but is
that's probably someone who's not
transgender and who's just rocking out
you know like as opposed to like again
like having a book called Chani where
like I hated that about myself you know
and I feared people knowing about that
that about me because I didn't accept it
completely relief I feel like you know a
transgender but just admitting that I'm
bi I still find it I'm okay with you
guys cuz I've already done it I did it
on Sam sherbert like I admitted a lot of
stuff on Sam's show but I didn't there's
still certain people that I like so
you're a bottom.i calm and you would
easily one room I don't want to talk
about you said we'd do it on your show
like you said there were stuff I used on
my show cuz it's in this room that you
didn't want to do on your show fruit I
just didn't want to announce it yeah
well I was you question me if you didn't
question me I wasn't gonna [ __ ] talk
about it right
you heard me on Pete Dominic and he
touched on a little bit so I was a
little more open to it but no one ever
asked me so I'm like I don't want to be
on like a loudspeaker and tell everybody
uh but if I get us looking a lie I want
to be honest and then honestly since I
told you on the show obviously nobody
caught it on YouTube but I felt better
that I did that I got it out yeah so I
guess from now on I'm Way more - I'm Way
more into talking about it because I I
don't want to hide well that's a big
part of it - like did you know and you
know you put out the book and everything
it was there a part of you even as
you're transitioning that's like I've
put so much time and effort and energy
into the music and into this band I
don't want people to forget about the
band and me become this thing that let's
just talk about this person in the
journey that they went through
transition you know because I mean like
the narrative of my band four years
before that was always like are you a
sellout are you not a sellout for
whatever record label I was on it's
never about the music being in a band go
out and you do press and like the press
is going to latch on to whatever story
they want to latch on to no one's like
what kind of guitars did you use on this
right
like you were stoked on a new amp you
got or anything like no one cares about
that no yeah no it cares about the
songwriting craft or anything like that
so it's always something that doesn't
matter and when it comes down to it like
you know maybe it would have grabbed a
couple headlines coming out or something
like that but like if the music isn't
good or if your shows aren't good no
one's going to care no one's going to
come out and see you what was the first
show you did after you came out oh so
lame it was so lame we played with the
cult and it was a show in San Diego and
it's like outside seeded venues venue
with like folding chairs and there's all
this like pressure people like oh it's
your first show as a woman it's like
coffee's just a show like we're just
playing a show we're opening for another
band didn't your voice sound different
no no it doesn't work like that it works
like that with testosterone but not and
I it doesn't work like that with us okay
so yeah I wouldn't thought the same
thing to tell you the truth that the
hormones would wouldn't bring you down
you're saying the same thing I'm saying
before yeah and the fans have been real
it's really the fans have been really
cool like certain performers you might
think yeah the fans but when you think
Punk or honk the fans would be harder
for them to accept that sure well I mean
like for most part you know I mean it's
like a line in the sand like you know
how many ones coming out to a show then
is on the same page as you but then also
like there was a lot of fans where
you're losing because like they felt
like they didn't feel safe at our shows
anymore especially as like we started
touring with more other more mainstream
acts and like there's more of like a
jock element at our shows where like
people are like I don't feel comfortable
here I feel like I'm gonna get beat up
for being a freak and that's not what
like punk rock is you know it's supposed
to be like a island of misfit toys at a
show
you said Springsteen gave you good
advice too he did he wrote me a letter
like but that was like in in 2007-2008
yes I saw the photo I was you before you
transition with yes yes son and what was
it about it was something to do with the
label um it was just about you know
people calling you sellout and not
taking that you know and just being true
to what you do and like as long as you
get up there on stage and give it your
all you know after that let the cards
follow me with MA you know like and it
just like really like it was real
supporter people think that if you do
alright building if you do well I go
Metallica cut their hair all the sudden
goes your [ __ ] soul I was like
whatever a band does something a little
bit different succeeding success or more
people discover you the fans
automatically interpret that because the
fans like to have this secret thing
right it's ours where's ours were
protective of it than any change or any
notoriety they think it's a cell which I
get I mean I grew up in punk rock too
but to me like selling out always meant
giving up on your dreams and like okay
I'm not going to play music anymore I'm
gonna go get some job I hate some soul
sucking existence that were chained by
the band to to fit a labels image right
right member Jason Newsted I saw video
of him in Metallica saying yeah we sell
out every seat in the stadium
I saw that so yeah but was that cool was
that did the Bruce thing I think I read
the didn't that follow like that that
there was an anti against me rally or
groupers I got like arrested the night
before right um
and like she's got a fight with a bunch
of people right yeah I kind of snapped
and lost it for a second I was in
Tallahassee Florida and I was in a
coffee shop and like went back to use
the restroom was coming back and someone
had taken like a picture out of the
weekly magazine and like you know
whatever wrote a bunch of [ __ ] on it and
I like tore it down and some kid got up
in my face is like why'd you do that and
like just got really rude with me and
then like turned around and walked away
and I like came after him I'm like
what's wrong with you you know I'm like
I'm a human being you don't know me why
you treated me like this and he was just
like so smug you know and he's like as
far as I'm concerned this cons of
conversations over and as far as I was
concerned it wasn't over so I attacked
him you know yeah I kind of feel it so
far as I'm concerned this conversations
over it must feel so good to hit a
person after that yeah yeah I mean I
guess I slammed his head into the table
jumped on him and then but I didn't
realize that there was an against me
protest show happening there that night
in the cafe so it was like MLG Pro tisha
yeah a protest really pretty sure they
were protesting us playing why because
we're sellouts what with they were old
faint or they weren't advanced like
we're no longer fan so like I didn't
realize this is before tradition is that
it was a fan was trying to fight you
yeah well ex fan I guess because you
more successful than he when he
originally started locking yeah and
again like we're playing really maybe
there was like 200 people of the show
that night it wasn't like huge or
anything and you know but I didn't
realize like everyone in that room was
like watching me the second I walked in
so like the second if I started
happening like
everyone jumped on me so it was like ten
on one you know they helped them like
there was such [ __ ] fans they helped the
fan in that they didn't they they jumped
on you totally and then they called the
cops hunks called the cops awful yeah
he's here well it's so crazy that they
were how did that feel like does it I
mean to know that there are old fans
that are so passionate they're
protesting you right well you know I can
that mean that like does it feel even
more successful that people care that
much it is no it was it to be [ __ ]
like all of it like all this like we're
going to start a revolution anarchy in
all this [ __ ] you know I remember like
you know we played this polish-american
hall on Long Island in like 2003 2004
and it was like a 16 year old fan [ __ ]
set it up it was $8 to get into the show
and people came they slashed our tires
so like a couple shows later we see the
kid who slashed our tires and there's
like about to be a confrontation
happening out in front of the show and I
look over and I see a punk pick up a
brick and I'm like whoa this kid is
potentially gonna bash my brains in
because he doesn't like the record label
we're on and we're on fat records at
this time we're not on a major label and
he's gonna kill me over this you know
and I was just like [ __ ] this funk rock
[ __ ] you yeah I'm out yeah cuz if people
just are using that as an excuse to
behave the way they want to behave it's
like what kind of thing it's that man if
you change record label it since it's
inside it's about something else totally
plus it's like you must get up there
like when you start getting new fans
like I want you guys to like me but
don't like me that much like just enjoy
the show
because last time we had passionate fans
they threatened to kill us because we
[ __ ] change record label totally and I
mean to me it was always just absurd and
it was you know like everyone's having
this argument like are you Punk are you
not Punk and it's like I don't care
privately I'm just like I have gender
dysphoria I don't know how to deal with
this your argument is stupid I just do
not care this is a farthest thing from
what I'm thinking about trying to figure
out if I'm schizophrenic or not I don't
care when you label my music I see nine
people in the mirror I don't care
so much more terrifying to know that
your fans would do that because of a
label then to know that you're gonna
tell the world that you're transgender I
don't that would really slow me down
somebody tried to kill me with a brick
because I was on a shitty label now I'm
gonna tell everybody that I'm a woman
what kind of group is coming for me now
like that did you think did that crossed
your mind
totally yeah don't you do drugs III do
yeah is he still running a little bit I
mean i-i've definitely calmed down I
smoke weed just that's it
yeah I mean I'll have a drink every once
in a while I was I've been driving for
the last two months I had a celebratory
drink last night we did this F Mayer
show or whatever how was that what's
that oh sure oh it's great really fun
yeah uh-huh
why'd you go dry for too much just
because just I had a back injury like at
the beginning of it we just did this
tour with Bad Religion I had a back
injury so I was taking like some some
pills some from my back and I was like
okay if I'm taking pills I don't want to
drink while doing pills you know
probably the one of the most interesting
things that I thought about the book was
just like you really go through how much
you struggled with this for years and
years and years and at one point you're
talking about you started by praying and
just trying to reach out to God and say
like okay if God exists he'll help me
and blah blah blah and then when that
wasn't helping you turn to say you tried
Satanism I my soul to the devil but that
for skateboarding you did hey [ __ ] you I
didn't like 13 I thought it was cool did
you write a little contract oh so clear
awesome best like a suburban angst I
signed it in blood like dude I know I
did I did - I signed it in blood yeah I
can't be on that side of the table had
everything in common and inside exactly
we all hate you
so we keep that a secret
god damn you all signed your name in
blood so my name in blood I just prayed
to him every night to let me be a
professional skateboarder yeah and guess
what he answered congratulations but I
got I got kicked out of church like my
church I went to a church and like they
started paying for me to see a
psychiatrist and then eventually like
told me don't come to church anymore and
it was like wow God is is telling me not
to go to church yeah wild
did you ever almost get caught growing
up like you must have been doing
something as a teenager whatever we like
well you came like this close to getting
outed or exposed totally yeah yeah I
mean there was one time like I'd skip
school and I was sitting on the back
porch of my mom's house on her smoking
weed and a dress and like the meter man
came through the back fence and I was
like [ __ ] so on sight you know and then
there was like another time where like I
like my favorite thing used to be like
I'd skip school and like there wasn't at
two hours of television where it was
like back-to-back episodes of wings and
quantum bleep and then MacGyver after
that shed I know yeah I don't I would
make myself clues and clue and creams
and sit into gluing creams all day in a
dress and just like while I'm watching
wings sisters are under any
circumstances anybody putting on a dress
and shipping beverages washing away but
I've had that one time and like and like
right before my parents came home and
like woke up seeing them pulling in the
driveway so there was like many close
calls like that and they would how did
it have they are they alive um yeah
uh-huh so they're cool all right
um I I haven't talked to my father since
I came out and why am i he I don't know
just say to ended communication like I I
wrote him a letter coming out you know
and tried my best to explain myself I'm
sure it wasn't that eloquent and I just
got like a cryptic one-word response
would say not one word but it said for
now the door is open but we'll see and
it was just like what is that mean wait
for now the door was open was there
other stuff that he was saying that
because of like what was it just because
of this I mean like my parents divorced
when I was like 12 years old or
something like that so ever since then
it was always kind of a strange
relationship you know my dad was army
broken a military family and it
it was what it was but my mother's been
really supportive and see dad is like oh
that's my son and this what slide after
a lot just the dads have a hard time
with it sometimes yeah and that's not
cool that's the most important one moms
have gonna understand but your dad when
he understands that then you feel like
the world has accepted you because that
that one for me would be come on man
like you think I'm doing this for
attention like RAM you got to understand
my and he's not he didn't give you the I
mean would like like Sam and Jim said
well you you weren't that closer than in
the beginning buddy I mean was he mean
to you we still friends before this yeah
I mean though he has switched off to you
yeah and I mean like you know I have a
seven-year-old daughter and it's like
you know he's no contact with my
daughter either it's just like just
seems that that's it that's it I was
asked you have a 7 year old daughter and
you've become a mummy kind of yeah I
mean she still calls me Dad you know but
she says she and her she's just like
it's not an issue to her didn't she ask
you that she wanted you to still be a
boy that was like right after I came out
yeah was it hard it was like
heartbreaking yeah I mean it like
totally destroyed me for sure you know
but now it's okay yeah I mean like kids
just want to know I don't I am and
they're they aren't going away
I know yeah unless you got pretty big
hands do you like tie it up and put it
back as it was that did you does that
new door like when you first started
doing that do you put it okay what no I
mean I I don't give a [ __ ] you know like
it's there for me like if it's hard for
someone understand that like sometimes
girls have a penis and sometimes boys
have a vagina then that's their issue
that's not my age I go there I don't
have a problem with myself and I like
coming out was totally liberating and
like completely like fixed all the
issues in my head in that way where it's
just like I am the way I am and
especially having a suicidal nervous
breakdown then after that it was like
you know what like there's an out I can
always just go and slit my wrists after
this you know like but since since I'm
not gonna then [ __ ] anyone who has a
problem with me and you know like [ __ ]
you if you don't get it and what a hug
but it's like we can do it later
yeah see I'm gonna be [ __ ] intense
okay that could be a tight one yeah I'm
not trans but sometimes I tuck anyway
just to show myself who's boss
Lord you feel like Jim's relating to you
on that hard I won't confuse it if ever
I live now I never understood tuck it
just seems remarkably uncomfortable it's
up looking up but I think this is like
these are these are like stereotypes
these are like you know like this is
like cisgendered person's like
understanding what it means to be trans
no trans people told me that like like
one girl I know it was she just went to
restaurants and she said that for her
the worst part besides like feeling like
yeah the dick didn't necessarily belong
SRS sexual reassignment surgery was was
going on a plane or going to the beach
and I've texted her since like hey how
are you since the surgery goes great I
can go swimming on the beach now and I'm
like I get that but that's also seems
like it's more about other people's
perception than like you and I mean like
totally totally yeah I mean I get I get
flags every time I go through airport
security check the provision body
scanner machines where they're always
like you have an anomaly in your crotch
brag about it cuz I'm like [ __ ] yeah
I've actually said that the people about
myself wanna check out my anomaly that's
that unusual that my chosen work
properly my pants on it a friend of mine
left those the underwear and the tie
thing in my bathroom once in like that's
actually tied devices call me a gaff
it's why my god it is all I wasn't sure
but I I hooked that bad boy up on me and
put it all in there in it and I was like
man I'm not like sitting down or
anything like I don't understand how you
how you pull it off yeah I guess you get
used to it some some girls are bigger
than others so I think maybe that might
help but a Morrissey quote no Judy Blume
believe I actually know that man that's
my only song that I know from her what
about it sure like the you knows when
you're talking about people's
perceptions and stuff how ready were you
to go from somebody who's literally I
mean struggled with this all their life
as much as anybody's ever struggled
anything suicidally struggled with this
for decades to then become this
representative of the community because
you know I wasn't ready for it at all
that's why I had a nervous breakdown
right now is like a year later it was a
public
too much pressure I'm yeah you know
losing it yeah because you do now have
to represent like trans in the public
eye for cisgender people to understand
but I always try to be really upfront
with people and be like you know I am
NOT a perfect person I do not have all
the answers I can only speak for myself
and for my experiences but why did you
turn down a half a million dollars I
read that that was one of the anything
to do with the fact that well this was a
major label and I've gotten so much [ __ ]
for being on other labels mean for music
yeah yeah I mean it was punk guilt for
sure but then they came back and like
offered us more money but also brown you
think that next time around we took it
right yeah taking the money is always
okay yeah I like Punk's think that they
have to be broke you know your fans will
Punk me well there's something about the
struggle that's like I think an
attractive thing like that like we're
gonna fight against the system fight
against the system and once you get paid
like will you fighting against you know
every single person that hates you for
taking that deal would take that deal
cuz I've been broke and I've had money I
never wanted better yeah you enjoyed the
money part a little better it's [ __ ]
really sweet right I bet it divorce so I
was once I was broken and I was rich
then I was broke again yeah every time I
come back up on my note to self sellout
but did you make the money is it harder
to write the same stuff like sometimes
it's hardly when you when you're
struggling against something you feel
shitty creativity works a little bit
better because it's just a reaction to
feeling shitty yeah but if you feel good
like it's kind of hard to find something
to push against a ting she is struggle
still yeah I'm sure like you know but
there was a disconnect like originally
being a band that you know we are an
anechoic ban you know so singing about
anarchism and that's why you get called
a sellout because like being
anti-capitalist and then making money
off of your move music conflict you know
those two things and singing about like
dumpster diving and stuff like that and
then you're like well I no longer
dumpster dive so what if what am I going
to write about now you know like that
that's identity you know and and that
that had a lot to do with dysphoria to
feeling like okay you know you latched
on to these identities that it was like
I can't express myself as I feel so I'll
be Punk and I'll charge out my hair and
I'll wear a big spiky leather jacket and
ripped up jeans whatever and then like
you you lose that identity and then this
for you comes out more strongly
so this is like last three years would
you say it's the first time in your life
that you felt normal
um yeah I like that I can be myself
especially like on stage you know like
I'm not up there being like Who am I
what are you people you know what is it
like to like not have that you know
because even it's an unpleasant thing to
grow up struggling and struggling and
struggling and when you finally fix it
are you prepared to not have that
struggle you know what I mean because it
becomes an identifying thing like that's
just who I am I struggle yeah when I got
hit in the stomach feeling right also I
mean you know is that the that's how
that's wrong actually you know like I
still don't have it all figured out and
my concept and understanding of gender
is still continually evolving you know
and it's not like I it like to say like
oh you transitioned as fall so it's like
you're in transition you're
transitioning you know but then really
that's life you know like you're
constantly evolving and like learning
and becoming who you are you know and I
don't have it all figured out I don't
like I have an idea of who I'd like to
be in ten years but I don't really know
who I'm going to be in ten years you
know but like when it comes down to it
like I still suffer from depression and
depression is a mental illness you know
and and it's not necessarily tied to the
dysphoria you know so I still struggle
you know like and I still like I mean my
life that I have on tour with my band is
one thing when I'm surrounded by
everybody but other than that like I go
back to Chicago and it's like boom
you're alone you know like and I don't
know do you uh so do you feel like you
want to go through surgeries or you
don't know yet or do you see yourself
down the road as being like having
breasts in a vagina or do you not wait
to think about that you just don't know
oh I have tits yeah no I don't know is
that Jason [ __ ] it wrong but I don't you
know honestly like tattoos have been a
good learning lesson with that we're
like you go in for a tattoo and you have
this idea of like a tattoo will look
like that and you know this is what I
want done and sometimes you come out and
you're like oh it's a little [ __ ] up
and it doesn't quite look how I thought
it would look you know or I don't quite
like it you know so like knowing that
with surgeries and stuff like that you
know you know that those titties come
out you happy are you Jason I don't know
I want to say I debated you can't touch
me a very
Jack in the Bing what's the Australian
phrase tits out for the boys is it they
say yeah yeah
which I love I want to write a song
called tits out for the boat show to be
a good one I'd love to hear yeah see
here I'd love to help you rot it
actually but you are you you're you're
happy with that party I I've accepted
myself you know I am plastic surgery it
doesn't fix a broken soul you know but
they look good though the point
hey I seriously think it's a like your
demographic is it's not old transgender
people don't the the people that you're
talking to or your fan base they don't
know about it like they live in another
world where they listen to your kind of
music and that's not around them a lot
so I feel like what you're doing I know
what you're doing what you what you've
got to do cuz you are who you are but
you realize it's a very important thing
like you're talking to people and submit
my radio show where I talk to a lot of
Neanderthals and if I'm bi they're like
wait you're supposed to smash it and
like titties I'm like I do
it may also don't mine like transgender
girls and every now and then if a guy
wants to blow me I might be into that
right it didn't it doesn't ruin me and
they're like wolf doesn't ruin you maybe
it's okay maybe I'll be more acceptable
to people like that around the world so
I feel like what you're doing I mean
it's helping you but you do know like
all the fans the music the people that
are into your music they don't know this
you're introducing them to it you're
like I don't want to do it but like
Caitlyn Jenner you're like Caitlyn
Jenner to real people not a bunch of
[ __ ] shitty housewives no disrespect
to them but you're usually stupid you're
joking to them the kids write me that I
feel like are more important than people
that watch the Kardashians on TV sure
but that's why it's important to be
visible and to represent who you are you
know yeah I respect that
yes seriously yeah and it is and it is I
mean as far as punk rock messages go to
be true to yourself to that level is
about as punk rock as you could be right
right I hope so that's what one would
think one would think well listen we do
you have to wait to let you go we've let
you go do your show
alright [ __ ] yeah Jesus yeah yeah
Stallone by but it's been great talking
to you everybody pick up the book and
your Tori who you're touring with now
with green
in March were going out with Green Day
okay great and the book is just called
[ __ ] Laura Jane grace and confessions
of punk rock's most infamous anarchist
sellout
my eyes are going badly I really am I
going to reach for audible I'm like I
have to do that because my [ __ ] eyes
suck Jim is transitioning into a very
old man yes I am doing a good job she's
got a bunch of signings though if you
want to meet Lori can tomorrow go to
politics and prose in Washington DC
Saturday Miami Book Fair sunday
books-a-million in Tallahassee Florida
November 21st in Ann Arbor November 29th
in San Francisco then Los Angeles in
Santa Monica
then on December 2nd back to Chicago so
keep an eye out for all those signings
and if she's not coming to your town by
the book thank you so much thanks for
really yeah it's fun thank you